I'M JAKER.AFTER
THY IN PRIMESECOMMITTEE WILL BEA
.W MUCH DOES THE COMMITTEE
KNOWT CURRENTLY?ME NOWA FORMER
ADVISED THJAh
COMONTHS ON E INSIDE, RM
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU FOR  RIG.
G
HERE.
>> I UNDERSTAND THA LOT
CA
SAVING IT FOR THE COMMITTEE, B
STTRUMP  A TI A
>> I THINK WITMESEE WILL
Y K IEX HEOT OF INDIVI
EXCITING WHEEYOMPRESS
THAT.WHEN THEDO BOTTO
FRLITARY
>> T
WHEN THEY THAT
I THINK PEOPLE WILL BE
TELY SURPRISED HOWUCWAS KNOWN W.
I THINATHA E
COMMITTEE.
Y
INATORS BEHIND THE. WITH AMS AN
THINGS LIKE THAT, WH T
FOUND.
AING OUSANDS OF
TEWSTA AND VIDEOS, I THINK -I DO
THINEY
TH ANYTHIN HEARINGS.
RESEMBLING AMO GUN, METHING THA
TT A
Y
SUPPTES
COUNTING THE ELEOR VOTES?
I THINK WHELOOK AT E  OF THE
OF THESE ARE MY PERSONAL
OPINIONS, WHEN YOU
OF EV, IT'S PARENT THAT DONALDE
WHAT WAS GOING ON.IF YOU'RE EET
VI
65F  PUSHI
THIS ON TWITANAL
MES IMPOU LOOK AT WHAT ANDTHE M
SOCIAL MEDIA AND OTHER
TART TE
OFON
THNGS
INIKE STOP THE
I THINK THE COMMITTEE WIE THE PL
IS IS -- LISN, HAD
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET THECER AND
GENERAL'S  ANDO
E AMICHI BEGINNING, TAKES AND UD
THE INVEATRT-BASED Y.G TO BPART
INDIVIDUALS.
THEY'LL PRESENT THIS CASE IN T N
TO TAKNOTES. T DOESN'T SOUND A .
NO SPECOO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION AND S OFF
>> THAT WILL BE DIFFICULT
AUTHORITIES OF CONGRS,AS GETTINS
ABOUT THE HEARINGS.TO THE
S THER
THERE ARE DIFFERENTHEY HAD
I THINK THATEEN THT LENGE FOTH
I DIDN'T KE
THISUC
IT'S ABSOLUTEL
D UTHE
K 6th WAS
AN C OPINION, S
OPINION,.
>> IT S?
F UPE U JUST GO BY
DICTIONARY, IF YOU LOOAT
GR JUS AERSPECTIVE BECAUSE WN L
BE CLEYEAH, I MEAN, ATTEMPTEUP
WH PEOPLE
HEER ABOUTT ARE --THEY'RE BLATA
UNTRTH.
I JUST HAD THED
FORTUNE -- IT'S ACTUALLY THE RT
INVOLVED WITH PI
T 2020.TH THE MMTE
I'VE BEELOAT THIS TAA LONG
ES MA UNIQ PERSPECTIVE
THAT WAS EVEN PRE-COMMITTEE ONW
REAL THRCAS A REAL CHALLENGE TOO
THOSE MULTIPLEED CHANNELS
SORT OF MAI  INSANITY INTO PEO'
HEADS.
ERE,
CHENEY, THE VICE CHAIRIS
COMMITTEHED THIS ABOUT
THE REPUBLICANTY
WEEKEND.
>> MANOPLE NOW
HEEPO ARE
RESPONSIBILITIES
LOYALTY TO NALDDGED THEIR
TRUMP.IT'S CONTRARY VATIVES LIN
ATT RTY
ING  PERSONALITY CULT, DO YOU
AGREE WITHCHARRI I
>> TA LT
.
GO SEE THA
KNOW, WITH OURE  MESSAEEFIRSTHAP
ERA ICSMAN. CONSIDER URREBLHINK
IME AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHIN
I'VE SE BSC
HAAYTHAT THE PARTY HAS MEDE PRI
S TALKING ABOUT.
CT YOU SEE IT
DO DATA,
COULD FOLLOW AT ANY POY INSANEHW
OF TOVIDVACCINATION CONSPIRACYOR
WHOU THINGS
IN TOTAL, THE FACTAT AHAUS AROU,
SH SUPENT, A-
THE ACTUALN PAPER
THROUGH PRIVAT